the following content is provided under  a Creative Commons license your support  will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to  offer high quality educational resources  for free  to make a donation or view additional  materials from hundreds of MIT courses  visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu  so I'm creating a variable called pset  time and I'm assigning it to be the  value 15 I'm creating a variable named  sleep time I'm assigning it to be the  value 8 I'm going to print the value of  this expression here and the expressions  a conditional that says is sleep time  greater than pset time so in Python  you're just going to replace these  values these variables with their values  so is 8 greater than 15 and that's false  so perfect and then a couple of  operations on or one operation on a  boolean is derive is true drink is false  I'm using the and operator to figure out  if I should drink and derive and I'm  going to print out false so perfect  people are getting in great job guys